what's up it's movie reviewing time yeah
this is good
I've been actually this is one of the
first ones that I wrote on the list
because this is one of my most beloved
movies from childhood and it's honestly
one that holds up like I've seen it 40
million times but I never get tired of
it yeah and it's time after time from
1979 yeah I grew up with it too it's a
good flick I haven't seen it in a few
years but you know this movie so well
you can go ahead and just gotta lead
this I know right it's like I remember
the movie though yeah it's good it's
funny because and I actually wrote like
kind of a big long blog post about this
and I went into this a little bit on my
blog that I'm kind of glad that I was
born at the time that I was born and you
too I mean you're a couple you're only a
couple years older than me because kind
of my formative years sort of coincided
with you know cable TV the home video
boom MTV you know the post-punk thing
that was Harvard that was our internet
for our generations yeah yeah so what
ended up happening was that for you
children at home I mean what I was in
for you too I was little you we only had
three channels and it was like a dial TV
then cable games well we had three
channels and then we had PBS and then
later on we got like a version of Fox 35
which may sleep mostly just showed like
Sanford and Son reruns they have our
barrel cartoons and [ __ ] like that but
then in probably I guess it was maybe 17
I never remember but my dad started
working as an installer for cable vision
in Daytona Beach and as one of the perks
of the job
he got all the channels free so we
didn't have to pay for cable and that
included pay channels which you know
back then that would HBO and I don't
know if they had Showtime then or not I
can't remember yeah but I definitely
remember having HBO and Cinemax
and remember how the big deal was
because you didn't have like smart TV
and she liked that you have you had to
have a box yeah and the first box that
we had was like this big clunky like
faux wood yeah box like it was
like a little sweeter eyelid yeah and it
up and there we go Atari was like would
think yeah it was like for wood and it
was like and there was numbers on it
that were like it was I wouldn't think
it went up to 42 or 43 and like that
seemed like wow 42 chilly [ __ ] how are
we ever gonna watch any of that stuff
looks like now of course we have like
3,000 you don't care the only thing we
ever watch on live TV is Walking Dead
but I sent all that to say that because
we got the pay channels for free and the
pay channels were not in a lot of homes
at this point they kind of had a lot of
movies that I guess were cheap for them
to get and they would play them a lot
you know I mean like they would go they
would have a set of movies every month
and they would put them in like heavy
rotation yes fine it did weird things to
your mind when you were a kid you'd
watch the same movie over and over again
they were almost become like religious
mantras yeah and you kind of like what
Bob where the movie yeah yeah oh that
one's back home look this lifestyle and
either watch it over and over again yeah
you knew all the lies and everything and
then you you know you you hang out with
your friends and you refer back to those
movies yeah never like what they said on
the shining I remember like they said on
you know yeah yeah you got to know he's
really well so we didn't really grow up
the way st. Millennials grew up yeah we
didn't grow up that way and I was gonna
say that and that was actually the next
thing I was gonna say wasn't one of the
movies they showed I mean a lot of them
were sucky yeah you know I said I think
I saw like the pirate movie and grease
to like that since no I'm speak as they
stop they show and then some of the
sucky movies were actually they suck
that they were cool you remembered them
anyway like shockwaves yeah yeah that's
not a it's a bunch of different ties
which is about Nazi submarines zombies
yeah but so I feel like you know even
though some of the movies were shitty
you kind I still have kind of like
affection for them like I should say
even though like grease 2 for example is
an objectively terrible but yeah like I
still like I saw it recently a nice
like oh it's us but oh yeah cuz I kind
of grew up with it however the main
movie that I saw and loved at this time
period was time after time and time
after time isn't objectively awesome
that's good and if anyone wants to argue
that I'll fight you because this is a
good movie oh I forgot something though
forgot something
forgot to tell people that patreon went
back to normal yeah cuz we actually it
and we said this on our last epic on one
of our last episodes that there had been
some I guess patreon announced that they
were gonna do some kind of change with
the fees yeah we're awesome selves and
we lost a few patrons you know which is
fine and that's understandable but we
just got a message that patreon has
decided are bad we're not going to do
that yeah all right and some patron says
some patrons really helped us out like
the the ones that stayed with us they
increased the amount that they were
suggest which I really appreciate it
yeah we ended up losing some patrons but
we actually did made the same amount of
money actually yeah and then one of them
stopped using patron but whatever to pay
fines pay pallets I wish patron wouldn't
do that kind of [ __ ] if they need money
they should have taken it from us not
from them yes I don't mind I don't mind
a couple tip a couple more percentage
from them I don't I don't blame them for
leave yeah that's what I man you know
patron patriot or patreon almost became
the next myspace because evidently a
bunch of people were leaving
like I said props to patreon at least
they made the announcement everybody
went no and they were like okay so we're
not this back to normal so yeah
apparently they're not gonna roll out
those changes so you know like I said if
you still like patreon we have a PayPal
account too if you just want to do
one-time support that's totally fine
yeah and there's a couple other services
paid patreon it's not a monopoly there's
a couple of them out there that we
probably should use because there's some
people don't like Pedro
yeah well yeah I mean I you know I'll go
into you know
diversified yeah so we'll worry about
that later but you're gonna hear this
this announcement over the next couple
of videos because we're gonna do a bunch
of videos at once we're not really sure
which one we're gonna post right next
yeah so don't get mad if you hear us say
this like free stuff but anyway okay so
time after time
like I said objectively good movie now
if you have not seen it you really
should because I feel like this is kind
of one of the most underrated movies of
the 70s a sleeper yeah it doesn't really
come up a lot and the only reason I saw
it was because it was on the pay
channels so much and it's actually it's
what could the movie is it it's hard to
classify it's an adventure movie I guess
it's a sci-fi adventure but it also has
some romantic comedy oh yeah and it also
has some horror
it's like slasher yeah it's a little bit
too and it's actually it was based on a
novel but the interesting thing is that
the novel was not finished at the time
the movie was made what ended up
happening was that the director Nicholas
Meyer this was actually his first movie
and he was actually friends with this
guy Carl Alexander and Carl Alexander
had written about 50 60 pages of a novel
that this novel and gave it to Nicholas
Meyer said what do you think about this
critique it and Nicholas Meyer is like
this is a cool ass story can I action it
and the dudes like it's not done but
okay so he optioned the the idea and
that went on to made the movie now the
novel did come out later I'm not real
sure how similar it is but the whole
premise of the movie and I love this
kind of game this makes this movie this
premise I love this premise yet because
I love the idea of like historical
figures like put in context where
they're not necessarily wait see Welles
makes a time machine in the 1800 1893
the movie I said in 1893 the beginning
Ernest that's the premise of the movie
he comes in to hard time well well yeah
he comes into the contemporary time bro
he was made and the reason that he comes
into the future is because he is friends
with a person who he didn't know was
Jack the Ripper yeah and Jack the Ripper
kills some people and he's gonna get
caught so he takes HD wells his time
machine into the future yeah so
she wants to chase him into 1979 yeah to
make sure he doesn't kill death alone no
weird thing about the movie is to eat
that the Jack the Ripper steals the time
machine takes it to the 1970s and then I
guess somehow it gets returned back to
the okay they do explain that all right
and the whole because the beginning of
the movie it said it's an 1890 it had a
return saying like yes right the
beginning of the movie is set in 1893
and HG Wells is having a get-together
where he's gonna show his little you
know stiff upper lip Victorian yeah
buddies that he really for realizing
been at a time this is Malcolm McDowell
at his best and he nails HG Wells I
really really love his character in this
and the the funniest thing about this is
do you know what the movie was that he
made right before this one right and
that's why he took this role because I
didn't think totally different Aguila
because I feel like up to now you know
it's because he was Alex in a closet
orange he was a no lucky man like he
always kind of played those types of
character so he wanted to do something
totally like it Caligula
I haven't seen that a long time so weird
but yeah so he shows them the time
machine and of course they don't believe
it and stuff like that although David
Warner I love David Warner by the way
yeah he plays dr. John Leslie Stevenson
aka Jack the Ripper although no one
knows that at this point but he is very
interested in machine and it works on
stuff like that but HG Wells explains
how the time machine works which is
coincidentally why Jack Tripper takes
off in it but it has a little key yeah
and this is the non return key okay yeah
so you can use the time machine without
the key in it
hmm but if you use it without the key
then the machine will return to its
point of origin right right like a
safety yes so that's how that happens
and then there's he also explains to
that there
is another mechanism that it is possible
to travel without the machine but you
will not be able to come back okay and
that becomes important later okay but so
yeah what ends up happening is that so
they're having this little get-together
and he's showing the time machine and
they're all like what they don't think
they do but then the cops come to the
door and be like hey you know what a
prostitute got killed we think it's Jack
the Ripper so like that even though I
should note that this movie is set in
1893 which is about five years after the
Ripper murders that row but it's still
possible that you could have an run
around so you know close enough and so
the cops come and stuff and then there
they find David Warner's I keep calling
David Warner it's been John Leslie
Stevenson as Derek they're saying they
find this medical bag and there's all
these bloody gloves and it's tough
they're like oh what he must see the
Ripper where did he go uh-huh and that
issue else goes down to the cellar and
he's like me yeah God in my time machine
and the time machine and then the time
machine comes back and was like man
we're in that [ __ ] girl right so then
he has to get in a time machine and he
goes to 1979 yeah how does how does she
how does he know the date it was a date
it was on there yes there yeah like if
you don't have like little I've never
had numbers on there this spun like I
yeah it's very stumbling it's very
steampunk before anyone knew what the
same talk was yeah and I really like I
gotta say I really like the design of
the time machine with I'm all the
colored lights and [ __ ] like that on the
side yeah it's kind of similar to the
one from the actual movie The Time
Machine which is based on the HT Elsa
but okay so the thing I love about this
movie it could have gone in kind of a
zany direction because you do have that
fish out of water element of HG Wells
going into 1979 you know he sees a woman
walking down the street in like [ __ ]
saran wrap pants yeah you know he eats
it at McDonald's yeah all that kind of
stuff and it is kind of played for
laughs but not in a way that's like oh
look at this idiot like coming into and
yeah he's walking around this little
people are kind of looking at me kind of
funny and he goes into one time heat I
remember he had some jewels yeah and he
wanted to trade them a jeweler for cash
yeah ha I went to a pawn shop that's
what it was and he noticed that the guy
had tattoos of numbers on his arms and
it's like what's that you know that was
from the concentration camp during a war
well you know this actually
world war remember that World War that's
not exactly what he said what he said he
does notice that got the numbers but he
doesn't ask him about the numbers okay
um he takes the jewels because before he
left he actually didn't have the
presence of mind to say you know I'm
going for in the future
they probably won't have the same kind
of money so he takes like some old
jewels he had he took his housekeeper
steel rings things like that he said
I'll need to cash these in so he did
have that much foresight yeah and so he
goes to a pawn shop and the jeweler
specifically says I told you I've seen
this movie somebody says I have to ship
memorize the jeweler specifically says I
haven't seen stones in setting like this
settings like this since before the war
okay
you know which point HG Wells goes war
what'd he tell he's like yes since world
war ii world war yeah he's like yeah
world war co he's like oh my god the
Second World War
because it should be noted that HG Wells
his character is very into I mean he was
kind of like a futurist he was yeah he
thought that the future would be a
utopia yeah HG Wells himself was kind of
like a simplex almost like a British
Fabian socialist yeah all right which is
kind of like a utopianist did he talk to
the future be perfect and when he gets
to the seventies he finds out it was but
what was cool is that Jack the Ripper
gets to the 70s and he's like oh yeah I
was right basically he was like this is
this world was made for me I was a man
ahead of my time yes really cool even
though it's clear that HG Wells is the
good guy and Zac there's bad guy
obviously it's there's kind of like some
interesting it's it's kind of almost a
little bit edgy kind of because it's
saying yeah
HG Wells optimism about the future was
misplaced [ __ ]
Yeah right and and and that Jack the
Ripper's dissatisfaction with the past
was justified because he gets he gets HG
Wells into a room and shows him
television and I'll intelligence look
all this violence the call this warfare
and all this murder yeah on television
what I enjoy they just they just love it
they use it as entertainment
yeah yeah the famous quote that he says
and he's like 90 years ago I was a freak
yeah oh I'm an amateur that's right
because he's showing you know like war
atrocities and gent like that so like I
said well the thing about the movie is
that I don't think either of them are
right really it's just that just in
Georgia it's just how they interpret it
Jack the Ripper sees the violence but it
as it ends up HUL sees that too and he
gets a little bit disheartened but he
also finds love along the way yeah so he
sees I think he sees he loses his
optimism but I think he sees the future
in a more balanced way yeah it's kind of
the same yeah says every age is the same
so he's not saying the future is better
or worse he's just saying it's it's the
same as it was yeah that's what he's
saying yeah he interpreted like modern
sexuality is kind of like a futuristic
utopian sex sexuality that he was
dreaming about in 1800 yeah and I know
this it's free love you know that yes
well here's that's how I rare well know
the funny thing too is that like I said
I like that they used HG Wells coming
into the future because HG Wells was
writing about the future
what's writing about the future and in a
lot of ways he was very ahead of his
time he was a very early advocate of
women's rights for example and that kind
of plays into the plot as well because
when he comes into the future obviously
he's trying to catch Jack the Ripper and
keep him from killing people because he
feels responsible because Jacques Ferber
that was his time machine you know he
was responsible projector of birth
coming into this time so when he gets
there the first thing he thinks is that
well I had to change my jewels and stuff
so obviously Jack the Ripper will also
have to exchange his currency so the
first thing he does is he starts going
around the bag
asking hey has there been another guy
who looked kind of Victorian who have
really old money and stuff like that and
it turns out that the bank he goes to a
bunch of him but the bank he goes to
where Jack Gruber did exchange his money
the woman that is the manager of foreign
currency is named Amy Robbins and she's
played by Mary Steenburgen fun fact I
believe that Malcolm McDowell and Mary
Steenburgen met on the set of this movie
and married right after this movie came
out huh so they were married for
actually quite a long time about 10 11
years something like that so you can see
the kind of romance that develops
between them was actually real because
you know like I said so it ended up
happening so you can really tell there's
like a lot of really good chemistry
between them but he likes the fact that
Amy Robbins is a very liberated 70s
woman she is very forthright yeah she
likes sakes she well she's like whoo I
like his his manner he's very manly you
know he had really cool duds and
handlebar moustache he's hit a little
handlebar moustaches little deerstalker
hats and stuff like that
so she just straight-up asked him out
yeah and he's kind of taken aback yeah
but he's like this is cool and when they
go out on a date and stuff like that and
they come back to her apartment and she
basically has to like jump on him
because he's like - yeah he's trying to
get he was trying to be like perfect
yeah he's like on the other side of the
couch and then finally she's just like
[ __ ] jumps out of him
and then he's like well I don't want you
to think that I'm making you do
something you don't want to do and she
says the great line she's like my god
I'm practically raping you yeah which i
think is very funny but I like that he's
just kind of rolls with it yeah you know
what I mean now I should say that the
reason you you might think well why does
this whole romance develop when he
should be looking for Jack the Ripper
it's because he thinks that Jack the
Ripper got killed
because they had an argument Jack the
Ripper runs out into the street and gets
hit by a car and then he gets taken away
and then so HG starts going all the
hospitals asking about him now at the
main hospital they say nobody came in
here under the name
Leslie Stevenson but we did have a John
Doe come in and he got hit by a car and
he died yeah so for a while
HG Wells thinks that he's dead and he
thinks everything's okay so he can kind
of but but you know but then prostitutes
are turning up dead and he realized that
it was still alive and said he has to go
find him so there comes a point where he
has to tell Amy that he came here in a
time machine because the Ripper starts
fighting if he finds out about her yeah
that she's the one that told HG where
Jack Cooper was because you know that it
was the whole thing with them money
exchanged and so he begins to target her
okay so obviously at first she does not
believe him because why would you you
know he's like yeah I'm actually from
1893 and she was us so she thinks he's a
nut and stuff like that so you go okay
I'll prove it to you
now I should note too that the reason
that he turned up and he actually turned
up in San Francisco in 1979 and the
reason that he turned up in San
Francisco is because in 1979 there was a
museum in San Francisco that was having
you know a a retrospective of HG Wells
and the time machine was in this museum
so that's how it got moved
that's how it got moved there that's why
he didn't turn up in London say right
doesn't travel through space and on
travels through time so to go to a place
the time machine has to physically be
there yeah the travel across it I guess
that's why and which was very funny to
me when I first saw there's lots of
little great details like he kicked out
of the time machine and it's all ripped
off and said like that and a little kid
that's like mommy who's that man that
little kid is actually corey feldman I
didn't really he's really young but when
I saw this still I was like oh yeah I
forgot he was in it so yeah he gets out
of there and style corey feldman
yeah yeah actually is corey feldman
there was a great little thing where he
he breaks his glasses I think it was
during the during the journey in a time
machine and so all of the [ __ ] from his
office and his lab and stuff like that
are in this museum display yeah so he
kind of just sidles over to his desk and
opens it
there's spherical senses like oh I
thought I got this so there's like all
these little kind of details like that
so Amy gets targeted she doesn't believe
in what he says he's from the past and
this is Jack the Ripper so he basically
has to take her to the museum they have
to hide in the museum they have to and
he takes her three days into the future
okay now three days in the future Amy is
dead the Ripper has killed her right so
she believes him obviously she flips the
[ __ ] out and then they have to go back
to three days previously they say okay
we just we'll just try to prevent it
because now we know when it doesn't
happen and where it's gonna happen do
you want to spoil this I don't know I
don't know oh yeah I'm just sayin so
it's a good retrospective so far that
you've given I think it's a good teaser
and you know a lot of people never
probably ever seen this movie yeah this
is a highly underrated very honor right
I mean I feel like like our generation
that could that probably got very or
forties you saw oh you probably did see
it if you had the pay channels back in a
day because they used to play it like
endlessly like in the early 80s it's a
good time travel flick it's - it holds
up I saw it about two years ago and I
said oh man I forgot how good this was
do you have this song EVD I do not have
to get maybe they have a blu-ray that's
what I mean I like to be crazy this is
one of my very very favorite movies from
childhood and oh I should add I saw this
on the wiki and also with mine getting
the time machine now yeah I won't wear
this one yeah I like that movie - like I
like this one more cuz it kind of has a
lot more going on in it but you know the
the one that the time machine movie they
made was from the 60s was good - but the
thing that I liked about this and I saw
this on the Wikipedia page so I'm out of
McDowell when he knew he was gonna play
HG Wells he actually found a record like
an old recording of HG Wells's voice so
he could do it so he said so I listened
to it except HG Wells's real voice was
like super squeaky or like high-pitched
right and it had like this like kind of
working-class British accent
yeah and he's like and I feel like
people would have laughed at the
character hmm if I had talked like that
because it sounded so strange so he said
well I have a you know people have a
perception that HG Wells sort of talks
like with a kind of upper-crusty British
accent so that's how he did it he's like
I didn't want him to become comical cuz
like I said there were like funny
moments in the movie like with him
eating at McDonald's and like ordering
at McDonald's and figuring it out but I
like that they didn't play it as zany as
that like they kept Hg very dignified
you know he was kind of like ice he was
a little confused about some things but
because he was so ahead of his time for
1893 he kind of you know adapted very
quickly although like you said the whole
thing about Jack the Ripper I mean Jack
the Ripper when he came to 1979 he
adapted immediately he was already in
Disco clothes or no this no clothes but
you know it's like in his 70s
suit he had the smoke sunglasses you
know he was like you're his element yeah
already so there was some conflict there
but I do like that they didn't make it
like he was kind that they didn't make
HG like a bumbling idiot you know there
were a few things he was confused about
but he pretty much started rolling with
it almost and maybe it less so that he
could get so it was mostly serious but
if that's the funny side well neither
one of them really had to deal with a
language barrier
true that yeah they don't suppose he
says yeah yeah because the English isn't
all that different but yes so if you
have not seen time after time you really
should see it as seriously it's one of
my favourite movies from childhood
yeah hearing you talk about again I can
watch it over and over and over again
and I never get tired of it
like I said there is some it's not super
gory there's like a little bit of gore
in it
you can be a 25 year anniversary blu-ray
brother yeah there probably is I should
probably look around but yeah cuz this
is one this is one movie like I said
that I never get tired of watching I
sometimes would confused with one called
somewhere in time which that Christopher
Reeve tried trying to go back in time to
meet some girl who saw a photograph yeah
I only saw that one you did it by
willpower yeah yeah yeah I didn't seen
that one in a while to that I remember
that being pretty good yeah I only
thought once but I remember it being
okay so your book like I think there's
more of a chick flick though from what I
remember I was a little kid okay but I
wish in yourself to go backwards in time
I wonder is that based on a Jack Finney
novel because that sounds like something
that Jack's anyone read again about
people that go back in time here
intervention foot novels buddy else were
a bunch of Twilight Zone episodes but
and they were all about going back to
some idyllic past it wasn't just a movie
he does you know he goes backwards in
time and something happens yeah I mean
but I don't really remember everything
about it I remember it associates
thinking it was as good as say like the
Elephant Man okay but not as depressing
yeah Elephant Man like the Elephant Man
I did too but it's all very sad well for
him all the same time but yeah so yes
time after time I definitely recommend
it all the acting is fantastic in it the
Mary Steenburgen is greatest David
Warner makes a great Jack the Ripper
yeah because he's kind of likeable even
though he's horrible yeah it's like a
villain yeah he's real slick ISM he
makes a good villain and yeah so good
acting all around just a really good
story it's just a great premise I hope
they don't remake it although I'm
surprised that they haven't by now but
they actually I should mention that they
did do last year they made a TV series
based on it okay um I think it was ABC I
want to say what if it was any good well
it got real mixed reviews and it got
cancelled after only five episodes
it doesn't mean anything anymore because
yes I guess it didn't get a lot of
viewers because they made 12 episodes
but only 5 aired and then they canceled
it um from like I read the plot synopses
just real quick on Wikipedia it looked
like what they did was the first episode
that was pretty much the movie like what
happened in the movie and then it kind
of went off on different tangents
you know when I lied to her Dora
continued the story because well I was
gonna say I guess the end wouldn't have
been the same because I'm not gonna
spoil the ending in the movie but you
know it didn't have that kind of thing
happening but yeah so I have not seen
the TV series but and it was just last
year was 2016 but I I heard it wasn't
that great like it really didn't get
very good reviews and got canceled
but yeah so I kind of hope they don't
cuz this one has a real charm to it that
I don't think they could replicate Roe
you know and like I said the night this
79 setting was kind of so important to
right away the story was you know so I
don't think they could really redo that
in the same kind of way which is the
room that we'd have to reboot it a
different film yeah you definitely would
but yeah I definitely recommend this
movie if you like that kind of thing and
like I said one of my favorites from my
childhood mmm and that'll probably do it
for this movie review yeah be sure to
tune in to our regular show on Tuesday
and keep an eye out for more movie
reviews which I usually post around the
weekend sometime I don't usually have a
schedule proposal but other than that we
will see you next time